basson mais c'est fini a alors les
salles de gym vont finalement pouvoir
rouvrir en zone orange votre première
réaction à cette annonce
ben c'est beaucoup de fébrilité surtout
on commence à voir une petite lumière au
bout du tunnel
donc on est content que les zones
oranges où v on espère que les autres
territoires vont suivre assez rapidement
pour une énergie cardio ça veut dire
combien de salles pour le moment il va
voir jim d'ouvert sur les vingt-sept gym
à travers le québec
ok donc c'est vraiment un début du
commencement pour vous vous faites ça
commun à partir de lundi rouvrir donc
les deux jim dans l'espoir je présume
que d'autres zones oranges un peu plus
tard dans le mois de février exactement
donc on peut vous dire que déjà à nos
équipes sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
préparer l'ouverture pour que le tout se
fasse de façon sécuritaire et avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé aux équipes ont
hâte de revoir les membres c'est ce qui
leur manque le plus et on a aussi de
revoir nos employés un oeuvre dans la
santé l'eau jean michel goudard dit un
petit peu plus tôt je comprends que les
gens ont besoin
il ya beaucoup de demandes pour lily
salle de gym et les besoins seront
réévaluées monsieur legault a dit aussi
par ailleurs que c'est une décision de
la santé publique d'avoir fermé comme
sales et les salles de gym et de tarder
un petit peu à rouvrir partout les
salles de gym
est-ce que sur le plan de la santé
publique est ce que vous êtes prêt à
rouvrir
est-ce que c'est sécuritaire pour les
gens d'aller dans des salles de gym tout
à fait si on se réfère on a déjà eu la
pratique on a tout mis en place au mois
de juin avec la distanciation les
masques les réservations d'où on pouvait
quitter fait de façon informatique
donc on pouvait retracer des gens et en
plus nous on avait mis des normes un
petit peu plus haut on nettoyait nourrir
plusieurs fois par jour pour s'assurer
de dominer les risques de propagation du
virus et ont eu raison parce que le
temps qu'on était ouvert on a eu zéro
clodion chez énergie cardio et dans
l'ensemble de l'industrie et votre santé
financière d'énergie cardio 10 11 mois
plus tard comment ça se passe on a fait
des débuts comme state oil on a
travaillé de pair entre autres on a eu
le soutien gouvernemental pour les
loyers et les les portes aux prêts et
les salins on a la chance d'avoir des
partenaires financiers importants comme
le fonds de solidarité ftq la bdc est la
banque royale et on a fait un travail
d'équipé avec nos bailleurs aussi donc
je sais j'avais dit je peux dire pardon
vous êtes plus endettés je présume que
oui de plus les prêts on n'en veut plus
tout à fait d'accord on a pris ces
risques financiers là parce qu'on croit
notre entreprise on croit ou bien qu'on
fait aux québécois de la santé physique
et mentale
on a tout fait notre casse tête pour
passer cette étape là maintenant on est
dans les tables de la relance et nous
aussi dans l'industrie des jim on va
avoir besoin du support pour cette
relance le la première c'est les
québécois reviennent dans nos jim et la
deuxième au niveau gouvernemental pour
nous aider dans le repartir la roue
qu'on a arrêté subitement martial y
penser mais vous avez pas gagné la
bataille que vous vouliez gagner qui
était celle de considérer les salles de
gym comme étant un service essentiel de
santé un lieu de santé pour les genres
on n'a pas gagné la bataille mais je
pense qu'on a marqué des points
les gens sont de plus en plus conscients
de l'impact des jam sur la santé des
québécois et on continue à travailler
dans ce sens là pour de travailler de
pair avec le gouvernement et afin de
faire en sorte que l'entraînement
devient une habitude de vie et que tous
les québécois optimisant santé
d'ailleurs nous on s'est tourné vers
cette vision là énergie cardio est de
plus en plus vers la santé globale des
québécois bonne chance madame tremblay
merci
oui mais